James Gunn one of the people in my life
that when he calls I just pick up the
phone and say yes do whatever you're
about to say it's yes the answer is yes
James Gunn is an amazing storyteller
that guy understands story and he loves
to tell story so when he wants to do
something you know it's gonna be fun
you know it's gonna be satisfying he can
take
I mean guardians the galaxy that was a I
collected comics as a kid love love and
still do that was a comic that couldn't
keep my interest it had grandiose space
it held these things and it still I
still couldn't get into it when he told
me he got that movie I I said well good
luck with that he says don't worry I
know just what to do with it and he
clearly did so here he is with Suicide
Squad - he asked me to come down what
can I say about it it's so secret I get
stressed when people talk about it
here's what I can tell you though
huge scope I've never done anything so
big met a lot of really crazy amazing
cool people made some new friends
one of which Pete Davidson is now he's
come to the rookie to play my brother
the miscreant Nair do well brother who's
always in trouble
versus the brother who's the cop now
they finally meet they understand it in
there he'd know brother John know that
we've learned already that his dad
abandoned the family when he was a young
man so he didn't really have a father
figure around it's something that it's
it's in his past
at one point John Nolan realizes that
his dad went off and started a new
family and that's how he he inherits a
car and that's how he meets his
half-brother that he never knew yet you
can do this you have a unique ability to
connect with people she's a psychopath
who enjoys mind games and dismemberment
it's not exactly my lane here tough
I mean I love my job I absolutely love
my job my worst day is a great day to be
able to go out and do a project meet
actors who are fun who enjoy their job
or good at their job who are wells of
talent within the mean you just
understand my kind of school
these people are bubbling with talent
they're just brimming with it would you
come into an episode of the show yes I
would really ok now you're doing you're
just making those connections and
bringing and tying those things in
that's what I imagined this industry to
be like we're meeting people that I
think are great and working with them
and that's what's happening